[Music]
hello there watching the press preview
a first look at what is on the front
pages time to see them what's making the
headlines
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kev mcguire welcome to both of
you
and staying right through until midnight
front pages then let's start with the
telegraph
which has word that british travelers to
france will no longer need to quarantine
on their return if they've had both
doses of the covered vaccine
the guardian reports that as part of the
same announcement plans for a so-called
amber watch list
for countries like spain which could go
red have been shelved
that change to travel rules is also the
lead story for the times which calls it
a boost for summer getaways the metro's
headline
is back to school in response to the
news that the government has now
authorized
16 and 17 year olds to be given the jab
the daily mail hears that the rollout
could be extended as far down as 12 year
olds
while the financial times reports that
the world health organization
is urging restraint from wealthier
countries on possible booster jabs
because developing nations still haven't
received
enough doses so let's get more andrew
pierce kevin mcguire are here welcome to
both of you
and that news broke at 10 o'clock
tonight that
the travel restrictions for a nation
like france why not start with that as
the telegraph does andrew
um that holidays from there are now back
on
yeah i mean there was great confusion as
to why france went on this
completely idiotic system called amber
plus so
if you went to france it meant you had
to uh quarantine for ten days when you
got back
and dominic rob the foreign secretary
confirmed what we suspected at the time
that the officials who decided that
france needed to be given these extra
precautions had conflated figures
uh with the french territory of reunion
which is
6 000 miles away from the french
mainland so
why that was deemed as such a threat to
british holidaymakers
going to san tropez or to provence
absolutely ridiculous anyway they've
seen the light
france is coming off that amber plus
list 4 am
on sunday but people who then return
from france this saturday are still
going to have to quarantine
for 10 days and i suspect quite a lot of
them will be very tempted to think
to hell with that um because if they
came back
uh one day later they wouldn't have to
quarantine
at all yeah and that's always been the
problem hasn't it with these deadlines
and the irony of course the reunion was
on the ambulance it finally goes red
also in the the same time frame so you
could go to reunion come back via
somewhere that was not france and still
be okay
and the other big headline i guess for
many people kevin will be
india goes from red to amber and
the uae with the critical international
hub of dubai
also going from red to amber even though
possibly from there
it'll be a struggle to track where
people have come in from
oh it will absolutely uh but that's been
the case all the time it's
relying to a large degree on the honesty
of people when they
land in the uk or even the uk where
they've been from
um but the question around uh
india uh and of course there's a lot of
british people of uh indian heritage who
will want to be able to see relatives so
it's not just about
holidays it is about families getting
back together but they
you know that question of france france
should never have been on that
ridiculous amber plus
list and they've just really righted or
wrong but it's been chaotic
all the way through you know india was
delayed
going uh on the red list because johnson
wants to go
over and have his photo with the leader
of india
um and then they had catastrophic uh
consequences but it does feel at last
as if they're moving in the right
direction and the prime minister who
said he
won't go abroad on holiday himself said
he understands now why
lots of people yearn to and the
government seems to
stop getting in the way all of a sudden
and not making
making problems all of a sudden feels as
if it's listening to the british public
which wants the system to be a lot
simpler
yes uh the seven day rolling average for
india
uh daily effectively is forty thousand
and six hundred
roughly um you know you have to have
trust in nations figures
uh with accusations of course that it
was under reported during the great
surge of the delta variant that they had
there
but in terms of green nations austria
germany slovenia slovakia latvia romania
and
norway all to be added to the
government's green list for travel
um if of course uk travelers are welcome
which is has been the great rub but
but for many families um andrew who have
not seen each other since pre-march 2020
this will be welcome won't it oh
absolutely and as
kevin's right for once this isn't just
about holidays this is a lot of people
have families across the continent uh in
india
and they haven't seen them for best part
of 15 months and that's been really
desperate
so i think it's fantastic that the
confusion is over
uh we've got a much clearer system now
the amber watch list that
nobody seemed to want to own up to
coming up with was scrapped before it
even started
there was a most unedifying ministerial
blame game who was
the architect of it was it grant chaps
was it somebody else
uh and um and and you know the the
uncertainty over whether people will be
able to go to spain as lifted too
because
there were question marks over whether
that was going to go on amber plus
france and spain are the two most
popular holiday destinations for british
tourists
and they can that they've now there's
time to still book up and go
september's not so far away either and
it will be
at least it will give a a a new lease of
life to the
absolutely battered aviation and travel
industry which has been
on its knees for the last 15 months it
really has and it's going to be great to
see tourists coming back
into britain because we shouldn't forget
how important in would invent tourism is
to this country
while our theaters are reopening and my
word don't they need
american and continental tourists coming
in and sit
bums on seats that's what we need yeah
the welsh government worth noting still
advising against all but essential
travel abroad and those they say who
have been to a redless country
can't even enter wales until they've
completed 10 days of quarantine
in either england or scotland first so
uh england rules i guess we need to
remind people and just in case uh you're
worried about the redless countries
georgia mexico uh the uh aforementioned
la reunion island
and mayot which i have to confess i
don't know where that is
any idea no anyway that's that's the
same
awkwards no it's a google mission for
later uh probably that's all on the red
list anyway
um the other big covert news of course
is about vaccinations for younger people
the idea about containing any surge in
the virus
through september into the autumn i
suppose so 16 and 17 year olds
added to the list of those who can get
it uh your paper the daily mail andrew
uh suggesting that all over 12s could
eventually be jabbed but
going at the speed of science we heard
from jonathan vantam today
yeah he i think he's one of the most
impressive communicators we've seen
during from the beginning to end of this
covid
crisis he's the deputy chief medical
officer he's
he's a short he's a reassuring voice and
he said he wouldn't hesitate
to have his own children he's got a
couple of children
under the age of 16. he wouldn't
hesitate to let to have them vaccinated
and the male is reporting that this
could go a lot further
16 and 17 year olds won't need parental
consent to have the vaccine i hope they
go for it uh
some of the vaccinations will be done in
schools because they're going to roll
out flu jabs in schools for the first
time
this year but the mail suggesting it
could be extended to children over the
age of 12.
they're already doing that in france
they're already doing it in the united
states
and that will require parental consent
but why not do it
we know that children don't tend to get
very sick
with kobe but they get covered which
means they're spreaders
and if they're spreading they could
spread that of course to far more
vulnerable people
grandparents older people so i think
it's
great news uh the committee the joint
committee on vaccinization immunization
it's changed its position because only
two or three weeks ago it was it was
cautioning against
16 and 17 year olds having the jabs but
they say that they've been analyzing the
data
and they're now of that view and it's
being this decision is being led
by the scientists not the politicians
yes and the specific concerns seem to be
heart inflammation coming reporting from
countries like america
but the suggestion is that that's from
the second pfizer jab
so if at the moment you offer the first
bearing in mind many 16
and 17 year olds will already have
neutralizing antibodies from having had
covid
then for now that will make a difference
but to the ft we go
now which is talking about booster jabs
and i suppose going into younger age
ranges
this idea of the moral question about
how far you you vaccinate your own
population
when the need elsewhere is so much
greater kevin
yeah it is and it's a world health
organization calling for
uh richer countries such as our own not
to
uh use all the vaccines on booster jobs
which will be third
jabs until large parts of the the poorer
world
are vaccinated because the figures are
alarmingly low
for those countries if you look at the f
the ft they're just
uh they're saying in perkin cooker it's
just one percent
of people have been vaccinated you think
in the uk now well over two-thirds
of both doses of the vaccine and it's
more than eight and ten
uh i've got at least one dose so i
understand where the world health
organization is is coming because the
only way we will defeat
globally is through cooperation
internationally
and it's that that old line which which
kind of neatly sums up the position
of nobody's safe until everybody is safe
however i can also see the huge pressure
on governments
including our own to give those booster
booster jabs to stop uh covert coming
back
in any meaningful powerful lethal way
in in the united united kingdom but i
think
there is a strong case now our own
government has joined others
in pledging to give some vaccine doses
to poorer countries but they tend to be
rather late
in the day and if we don't uh cooperate
internationally and cooperate
better there is there is a chance that
we will be threatened here because you
can't just build a wall
to keep out code and we've seen that
well yeah you can you can try and stop
flights
and people coming into the country but
you will then
absolutely damage the economy yes and
the uk government at this point always
uh makes makes the point that they have
been a large contributor to the oxford
astrazeneca
vaccine which is being given to the
world at cost it has to be said for the
duration of the pandemic unlike other
vaccinations um quick word down the
bottom of the daily telegraph
andrew it's how to greet people we all
we're still at the
you know that moment don't we the
awkward moment um but the french are
ready to kiss goodbye to their czech
peck
it says here well i don't think that's
ever going to happen
they're so culturally attached to them
and uh but i mean if it means people
don't have to snog president macron what
that's a good thing
and they're talking about getting rid of
the cheap because of kobe but i just
don't think it's going to happen
and and it's not just the french after
all who do it we do it quite a lot in
this country too
old kevin mcguire thinks he's ever so
trendy because he does it all the time
yeah it's definitely spread hasn't it
like a virus i suppose
by the way can i just tell you something
my is a french territory
oh is it oh did you manage to do that
while he was talking was his answer that
long
yeah it went on so long i thought i
might as well just amble through google
because maguire is going to waffle on
for another 10 minutes
it's a french directory quite a long way
from france but um
uh so um and that's that's gone on the
red list hasn't it yeah through
google nobody angles through
you might amble through a passage
through your answer oh dear you
if i either can i just say i wanted to
come back on that world health story
we've got to give boosters first who's
going to what government is going to say
to
85 year olds in care homes you can't
have a booster jab
it's just not going to happen yeah and a
130 000
dead today it's not like this country
has not been hit
i suppose is the point isn't it um still
to come including she was four years old
during london 2012 but today
skateboarder sky brown made team gb
history
more on her remarkable achievement next
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney why
meeting you fishing does have the
potential
to stymie an enormous economic
deal we take you to the heart of stories
that
shape our world what strikes you when
you come to this glacier is not just the
way in which the environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
[Music]
do
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pearson
kevin mcguire welcome back to both of
you
and who knew there wasn't an age limit
for the for the olympics and
the skateboarding certainly delivered
some youngans didn't it kevin amazing
stuff from uh
sky brown and others oh absolutely
now the youngest medal winner
in for a hundred years i think wasn't
wasn't it she's broken the record the uk
just
13 years old and then i thought oh
that's incredibly young then he found
out the
japanese person who got the silver was
only 12
but actually she's just absolutely
brilliant